Okay, Michael, you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Alright, what's the answer?
>> So I was thinking about A before you threw in the B. So let me,
let me not think about B yet. I'll just think about A. So you had said
in state one, it can go either left or right. And in state four, it can
go either left or right. So boy, that
sounds a lot like two times two equals four.
>> Yes that's exactly right. But generally speaking, so actually walk
me through that again Michael. How did you get two times two?
>> So, well I, I had a little choice about how
to think about it. One is that in some sense, if you
go right from one, then you don't really have to make another choice.
>> Right.
>> But if you go left, then you have this other choice
to make of either left or right. So it's, you if, if
you're just writing it down as a mapping from state to action,
you've got two choices at state one, and two choices at state four.
>> Mmhmm.
>> And so that is two times two, right?
You can make, independently choose each of those.
>> Right, that's exactly right. So in
fact it's important there that even though
if I can gone right on one, I would never, have to make another choice
because I can't reach state four. In order to be a strategy, you have
to basically say what you would do, in all states where you might end up.
>> Okay, that's fair.
>> Okay, alright so what about B, using that incredible reasoning?
>> [LAUGH] So yeah, so B seems a little trickier because
here it can only ever matter whether you're in like if
player A sends us down to the left then we have a
choice of three. If player one sends us down the right, we
have a choice of one, which is really no choice at all.
>> Mmhmm.
>> You can have any color car you want as long as it's black.
>> Yeah, like my Tesla.
>> I was thinking the Model T, but maybe T stands for Tesla.
>> T does stand for Tesla.
>> So, by the definition of how
many different you know, sort of reachable strategies
it would be one answer but, if you're defining it the
way you're defining it, it's going to be three times one or, three.
>> Yeah. And that's exactly right. Good Michael.
So, let's actually write down what those strategies are.